bom dia a todos é sempre bom né
está no palco como
a telmex e na para mais tendo o primeiro
hoje 1º primeiro explica
eu quando vi o convite é para participar
aqui confessa que não querem comer e
vamos explicar porque eu tenho uma
empresa é um pouco mais leve e tudo que
eu tenho ouvido falar çom sobre
empreendedorismo até esse dia até o dia
que a empresa era que era um mundo
perfeito investidores na banheira onde
vemos tudo onde crescemos como rapidez
enorme mundo era um carrinho de frente
do campo no vendido ao longo desses anos
assim é difícil e por isso é que eu não
me lembro se eu falar hoje sobre o
empreendedorismo sobre o que nós já
estamos habituados a ouvir todos os dias
é mais do mesmo que vocês já devem estar
farto você falar um bocadinho sobre o
que se passa
então como português que sou decisão
para a última e só ontem é que eu ia
falar e vou falar dos dois vou misturar
embora o empreendorismo esteja sempre na
música vez mais forte e tentar
concentrar cada vez mais quando também
tem coisas extraordinárias é uma vida é
extraordinária e e evitou falar e como o
tema de hoje é partilha eu tive aqui
quadrados duas histórias histórias da
minha vida é curta é a primeira no
início sobre como tudo começou
falou sobre como eu comecei este projeto
porque é uma pergunta que as pessoas não
está nem sempre é eu tenho idéia de como
é que o meu começo eu gostava de dizer
que um teste quanto vocês já tiveram uma
ideia mas nunca
só não contava que ontem o quanto eu sou
mesmo muito a e é isso que eu quero para
que as duas têm ideias mas não consegue
dar o primeiro passo
e assim é muito mais fácil do que as
pessoas pensam as pessoas tendem a
complicar e história que vou contar nos
shows há dois anos desde que ela tinha
60 anos e um rapaz de 17 anos estava a
estudar no senai segundo ela e pensei
que finalmente encontrá lo
o fim de tanto tempo uma solução
patronal - tudo um caminho já tu nunca
estudaram e que eu fiz foi comprar um
casal foi preso no quarto
pensava eu tinha encontrado a solução
durante o percurso académico lápis mas
nunca chegamos a uma coisa
entregamos a folha toda preta é a caneta
embora as leis muito bem é permanente e
nós não podemos errar quando vemos é uma
coisa que temos é que ele vai para o
lixo e eu acredito que nós para aprender
o sistema de carga e nós não podemos ter
medo do erro
temos mesmo tempo estar livre e era
escrava quadro branco e foi por aí que
eu comprei quadro branco
só que ele não vai trazer mais problemas
para as lentes
podemos pegar tudo em sem pensar nas
consequências só que a vida não podia
arrancar da parede logo a professora
o caso também é pequeno os grandes são
muito caras
o maior problema ainda é que eu tenho
está em pé é e as poucas horas que já
estava ele estava estava cansado mais
rápido
portanto a igreja é uma solução e foi aí
que meus 60 anos resolveu solucionar seu
problema
o que eu fiz foi criada vai pegar no
quadro branco literalmente e transformar
a imprensa escrita é transpor essa
expressão escrita pela mulher na praia
do portátil que eu pudesse falar na
minha mochila todos os dias na conta
dele
luto é o fiz o primeiro protótipo uma
coisa muito simples mesmo reconheceu ter
usado nas minhas aulas e os meus amigos
foram ficaram curiosos sobre o que era
aquilo e eu vi e falando de dispositivos
e eu vi que podia ter uma oportunidade
de negócio e falei com um amigo meu com
espírito empreendedor
decidimos avançar com essa quantidade
fizemos um segundo protótipo eo que nós
fizemos
nós temos tempo nem se ela não sabia vai
querer comprar isto vamos tentar marcar
uma forma barata e que nos consumiram um
tempo fizemos um cross selling que o
caso não tem custo nenhum e que na
melhor das hipóteses nós temos uma
empresa apenas de hipóteses vamos
aconselhar não está no dinheiro
aprendíamos temos aprendido alguma coisa
o mesmo percurso
essa campanha drogas também foi um filme
surpreendente para nós foi foi muito
simples
primeiro começamos a convidar a nível
familiar plantamos do ar em combinar am
e mais tarde foi a presença de estranhos
pois nós não conhecemos lá nenhum e
alcançou o pneu muito nós temos duas
pessoas que nos deram nos anos que lula
vem acontecendo há nenhum
nós apenas temos um protótipo uma
promessa não se lembra dela e nós com
isso atingiu us 185 cento do montante
tinha sido inicialmente e do nosso
negócio criamos a nossa empresa tanto
foi algo extraordinária e é assim tão
simples
é mesmo muito simples portanto o
conselho que eu quero outra coisa eu sei
nada negócios nada de vendas
você não sabe nada da vida basicamente
não ser muito fã
basicamente eu estou aqui agora como
empresa sucesso internacionais inclusive
com um bom trabalho
portanto eu comecei a receber nada e
isso o conselho quer dar
se você tem uma idéia que querem ver com
o projeto
enchem os olhos e avança porque não vai
continuar normal
na pior das hipóteses ficam como estavam
antes
na melhor das hipóteses em um clima
estranho empresa criou um produto ganhou
dinheiro portanto não tem nada
esta é a primeira história a segunda
história vôo que um leão ao que escrevi
na minha empresa fez um ano depois já
com medo pois tem um uma patroa
então hoje temos para baixo
atingimos um marco que muitas empresas
não atingem nós fazemos um ano
o cenário por isso já passou um ano de
muita aprendizagem vitórias e dissabores
sofrimento e principalmente muito
sofrimento
parece que foi ontem começamos a gravar
em que acordava todos os dias com
sorriso no rosto com vontade de fazer
mais fazer um projeto em a vida parece
que foi ontem que a faculdade não
entrando em toda a minha vida mudou nos
últimos tempos não têm sido melhor
depois perceber como funcionam os ditos
grandes empresários portugueses depois
de perceber que existe no mundo dos
negócios
tenho nada talvez mais animado e como
voltarmos ao mundo
fazendo uma retrospectiva para cometer
seus amigos das festas nos tudo tudo
isso em troca que em troca uma perda da
inocência só deveria acontecer pois teve
dúvida ao máximo
ele está contente de estar orgulhoso o
percurso como o senhor ficar na mesma
porém ainda que a distribuição por
vender para grandes empresas sendo
atualizado revistas conhecesse o topo
para atingir coisas tosco tripla minha
da noite já está sempre foi um sonho
estar aqui é avião já não ocorre com o
mesmo sorriso nem comer uma votação do
mundo
só gostava de saber porque finalmente
escolher razão e é sobre essa conclusão
a que eu cheguei e quero falar quando
saiu o projeto tenha um sócio
meu amigo que por razões pessoais teve
que sair da empresa
e até lá tudo que nós precisamos é
motivo de comemoração
nós abrimos a nossa empresa é
oficialmente
vamos buscar uma figueira entramos na
incubadora no porto é a mesma coisa
vendíamos não querem mais normal também
portanto era tudo mesmo motivo que o
brasil não era especulado am e sempre
tinha alguém para partilhar e não
exportava muito e sucesso essa cidade é
com a saída viável
eu pensei ah e viver esse momento estou
sozinho
portanto houve uma fase complicada e só
há dois meses
é quando conhece uma pessoa também
apaixonada pelo empreendedorismo
iluminava o que é muito difícil
encontrar agora a partilhar todos os
momentos com ela é que faltava para eu
continuar a ter a mesma vontade de mudar
o mundo era ter alguém com quem
contempla um sucesso eo conselho que eu
quero dar é nunca cria uma empresa
sozinha já é possível
claro que sim alguns exemplos os casos
de sucesso muito sucesso
é muito mais fácil criar uma empresa com
alguém
não digo isto em termos técnicos a
partir das técnicas
digo isto mas a nível emocional mas não
se coloca porque vocês como fundador de
uma startup são duas três pessoas quatro
no máximo em todas
todos os dias tomar decisões importantes
porque vocês não somos empregados
ninguém não podem deixar as coisas com
outra pessoa
se querem que os 80 e vocês a fazer e
isso é muito cansativo ano em outra
coisa que eu tenho visto a ver com
quantos mais dias normais
então num dia em que o mundo quer em
seminários
isto num dia em que pensam que ele não
falou nada
a empresa vai acabar a equilibrar essa
balança que é muito muito importante
começar a empresa com outra pessoa e por
fim quero outra coisa usar o conselho
que é muito simples é uma coisa normal é
um dos sonhos porque nossas idéias
custar porque não vão ser as pessoas que
disseram que não valia nada e se vocês
querem com sala chegar aos 180 anos a
olhar para trás e pensar o que poderia
ter sido se muito importante nos
negócios é muito duro é vocês vão sofrer
muito
o secretário verdadeiramente nossa idéia
vocês vão passar todos os obstáculos
outra coisa é no meu caso eu posso dizer
que passei muitas noites sem dormir
continua a passar a trabalhar mais do
que alguma vez que entrava nos anos 1990
sem dúvida e nunca pensei em trabalhar
tanto pra mim o mais importante não é
isso pergunta mais importante vai fazer
é se vale a pena
a minha resposta é claro que sim eu vejo
os conhecimentos que fui adquirindo um
tempo e é qualquer coisa extraordinária
porque o projeto sozinho e já estou um
patamar onde continua a ser uma empresa
pequena mas domingo 18 anos é uma
extraordinária em uma frase que eu gosto
muito do doce o norte americano
muito sucesso ela diz que o
empreendedorismo é ser empreendedor é
como tratar de um precipício e ter
construído o próprio paraquedas
eu acredito muito em breve na água e
apoio 100% porque uma é algo tem muitos
altos e baixos é sem sucesso
e no meu caso olhar para trás e ver era
tudo que já atinge fazem crer que nesta
semana foi mais do que eu na minha
nos dois anos que o necessário foi uma
coisa extraordinária e é isto que eu
quero continuar a aprender e claro que
vale a pena vale sempre a pena e um por
fim o que eu queria dizer que eu estou
sempre acesa fiada estou sempre a
trabalhar na minha não limita a minha
zona de conforto
eu todos os dias todas as afiadas e
melhor
o que eu quero o que eu quero dizer para
acabar o tempo é israel nossa zona de
conforto e acreditem